Hello world,
it's Saroj and drones are a lot of fun.
We're going to train a drone
in a simulated environment
to be able to fly to any
location. We give it autonomously
avoiding numerous obstacles.
It's never seen before.
Along the way,
we can think of drones as
aerial data capture devices.
Each one can potentially hold
a huge amount of sensors,
although right now most of them just use
a camera and if we connect a drone to a
data storage and analytics pipeline,
we can solve specific problems
using the data it's captured.
For example,
a startup called sky specs is using them
to identify anomalies for wind farms.
When a wind farm has motors that
are running hotter than they should,
they're drones are used to help monitor
the humidity and weather conditions to
more quickly identify when
a problem will arise. Also,
Cape is playing a vital role for mining.
Companies are providing volume metric
mappings that help them measure their
stockpiles with their high resolution
imagery fed into an image processing
pipeline.
The accuracy of asset measurement
can increase by up to 20 fold.
It's these type of measurements that
help companies transition from a discrete
to continuous forecasting cycle.
Forecast don't have to be made in
intervals. When you have a drone,
it can be an ongoing process.
So before we start talking about the
theory behind how we're going to train our
drone using machine learning,
let's take a look at this simulated
environment called the Ross development
studio.
Ross or the robot operating system is a
framework for writing robots software.
It's a collection of tools that make
the process of architecting our robot's
behavior much easier.
It's goal is to enable code
reusability in robotics,
research and development.
Robots can have all sorts of hardware
components from arms two legs,
two can openers to seven
different types of sensors,
all performing different
tasks at the same time.
And while all of these hardware modules
might be performing different tasks,
they all still have to talk to each other,
which can get complicated to architect.
What Ross does is it lets us abstract
each of these components as individual
nodes and once we have our
drivers installed we can use,
it's built in communications layer to
create a cohesive integrated system with
concurrency support enabled.
The Ross runtime graph is a peer to
peer network of processes that are
potentially distributed across machines
coupled together using the Ross
communication infrastructure.
The Ross Development Studio
is an in browser environment,
meaning we don't have to install
anything on our computers to use it.
We just had to visit
the link in our browser.
Once there we can create a new
project and name it something unique,
then we can open the project by
clicking on the open project button.
Once we have the environment open,
we can go to the tools menu
and open a Linux shell.
Inside the shell will go
to the source directory.
This is the place where Ross code has
to be put into the rds in order to build
tests the bug and execute it
against robots simulations.
We can pull our code directly from get
hub right here if we wanted to to train
our drone and then watch the parrot drone
simulation under the simulations menu.
Finally,
we can launch our package so it will
start training the parrot drone right from
the shell using the Ross run command.
It's going to start moving and wild ways,
but that makes sense.
What our robot is doing is learning
using an algorithm called deep the
terministic policy gradients.
Sounds complicated. I know.
So let's take a step back.
Traditionally,
the class of algorithms
considered reinforcement
learning only really worked in
tiny disc retired grid worlds,
and that stopped them from
gaining credibility as being
viable real world tools
for context. Discrete data
can take only integer values,
whereas as continuous data can
take on any value for games,
that difference boils down to either
a few set of possible actions or many.
When deep mind released
their deep reinforcement
learning algorithm called deep
to the Ai community,
saw that deep learning methods could be
used to solve high dimensional problems,
powerful stuff.
Perhaps it could also be used to
deal with continuous action spaces.
Learning and continuous action spaces has
been a huge obstacle for AI developers
and the most interesting real
world problems in robotics
control fall into this
category if we disc retired our continuous
action space to finally we'll end up
with what's called the
curse of dimensionality,
which basically states that the
more dimensions you work with,
the less affective
statistical techniques become.
But on the flip side,
a naive discretization of our action
space ignores valuable information about
the geometry of our action domain.
So deep mind created an
algorithm specifically to
solve this continuous action
space problem called deep
deterministic policy gradients.
It uses a mixture of two techniques,
policy gradients, and actor critic.
Let's take a look at how both work.
First policy is a mapping
of states to actions.
It's how an agent decides how to interact
with an environment and an optimal
policy can be learned.
Policy Gradient Algorithms are a set of
techniques that optimize a policy end to
end by computing noisy estimates of the
gradient of the expected reward of the
policy. Then updating the policy
in the gradient direction.
The gradient is a signal that we derive
using calculus that tells our learning
agent how best to update its
knowledge of the environment.
The algorithm will observe many training
examples of high rewards from good
actions,
negative rewards for bad actions,
and it'll slowly increased the
probability of the good actions over time.
But in practice,
getting one reward signal at the
end of a long episode of environment
interaction makes it difficult to a
certain exactly which action was the good
one. This is popularly known as
the credit assignment problem.
One way to solve the credit assignment
problem is to use an actor critic
algorithm.
Actor critic algorithms
are used to represent the
policy function independently
of the value function.
The policy function structure is known
as the actor and the value function
structure is called the critic.
The actor produces an action given the
current environment state and the critic
produces an error signal given the
state and results into a reward.
If the critic is estimating the quality
or Q function that assigns values to
possible actions,
it will also need the output of the actor.
The output of the critic drives
learning in both actor and critic.
We can use neural networks
to represent both of them.
So the deep deterministic policy
gradients algorithm combines both of these
techniques.
It's a policy graded algorithm that
uses a stochastic behavior policy for
exploration,
but estimates a deterministic
target policy which is
easier to learn for context
in deterministic models.
The output of the model is fully
determined by the parameter values and the
initial conditions. The castic models
possessed some inherent randomness.
DDP PG uses a form of policy iteration
in which it evaluates the policy then
follows the policy gradient
to improve performance.
It's also an actor critic algorithm
in that it uses to neural networks.
They compute action predictions for
the current state and generate an error
signal at each time step.
The input of the actor network is the
current state and the output is a scalar
value representing an action chosen
from a continuous action space.
So the critic output is the estimated
Q value of the current state and the
action given by the actor.
A specific theorem called
the deterministic policy.
Gradient theorem is used as the update
rule for the weights of the actor network.
The critic network is updated from the
gradients obtained from the error signal.
There were two tricks on top of that that
the team at deep mind used to improve
convergence.
The first is using an experience buffer
using a replay buffer to store the
experiences of an agent during training.
Then randomly sampling from it while
learning has proven to be beneficial and
the second is using a set of target
networks are using a set of target and
networks to generate the targets
for our error computation.
We regularize our learning
algorithm and increased stability.
We can create a custom environment class
that uses Ross function calls to define
our robot and its environment.
We can start by registering our
environment into the pool of available
environments of Open Ai's gym library.
Then we can get the
configuration parameters
directly from the Ross parameter
server and connect it to the
simulation called Gazebo.
The main function is the step function.
It's called during each training loop.
This function receives as a parameter
the actions selected by the learning
algorithm. This parameter is just
the number of the action selected,
not the actual action.
Our Algorithm won't know which
actions we have for this task.
It only knows the number of
actions available and picks
one of them based on its
current learning statics.
We'll convert that number into the
actual action for the robot ourselves.
After that,
then we send that action to the robot
through a series of steps as follows,
unpause this simulator,
send the command,
wait for the execution of said command,
observe the state of the environment
and again, pause the simulator.
Then we processed the current states,
calculate the reward,
return the current state,
return the reward and return a boolean
value indicating whether we're done or
not, meaning we completed
our objective. That's it.
When we test our robot out
in the simulated environment,
we'll see that at first it's
very sloppy in its movements,
but eventually it gets really good
at navigating our environments.
No matter how many obstacles it faces,
we can then take this code and run it
on a real drone as some developers have
and eventually apply it
to a real world problem.
Three things to remember from this video.
The robot operating system allows for
code reusability amongst roboticists and
is currently the best free framework
out there to architect a robotic system.
We can train a drone to navigate an
environment using the deep deterministic
policy gradients,
algorithm or D.
DPG and DDG is a mixture of policy
gradients and actor critic able to solve
tasks in continuous action spaces. Please
subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now, I've got a
fly, so thanks for watching.